this [__] hysterical this is
ridiculous
you can't keep doing this while I'm
drunk I can't watch it
I can't watch are you are you getting
this on video
got me pumped Joe's gonna go off here
dude jeans on jeans on jeans up up here
up here they're so flexible companion
from here turn your shoulder to the
right turn your shoulder to the right to
the right now extend extend extend
straight don't look over your stomach
look over your shoulder okay like this
like that that's how you look I know
that's the end
you are flexible you're fine look right
from here watch
lift your knee up and then kick I still
think John Claude Van Damme beats the
[__] out of both of you first then kick
watch one
two okay ready I'm not mad at Joe's form
at all no